ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
Dylan show can everybody just be nice
just be nice
that's the ethos of America it's just be
nice can't you be nice
everybody's got problems everybody's got
problems even the cop who put his knee
on that guy's neck and murdered him
doesn't he deserve our our pity
shouldn't we be nice to him
shouldn't we be nice to people
shouldn't we be nice to target why not
its target it's our friend target it's
uncle target why in god's name would you
ever damage a hair on the head of uncle
target or aunt Otto's own art I can't
these are corporations they're our
family they're our family they're more
important than people
well corporations are made of people Tim
shut up
they're made of slaves and drones with a
few people
what is ways they accomplished to burn
down your community
well what community the people that are
burning the community down don't own the
community they've been prevented from
doing so with laws that have prevented
them from owning the things so maybe
they don't have an attachment to it like
you do maybe they're not as attached to
it as you are because they didn't
inherit a home with a nice law
in a big backyard and they didn't get a
small business loan to start a business
they don't feel as connected to the
community as you do because cops can put
única step on their throat whenever they
want so they don't feel as connected to
the community why would they ever touch
target that's where I bite off you
should be looting target regardless of
what the [ __ ] cops do you should loot
target every day you should wake up
leave your house and loot target the
government of this country shut down the
economy gave you twelve hundred dollars
and gave billionaires the rest of that
bailout it was the largest transfer of
wealth and [ __ ] human history and
people are upset because somebody ran
out of target with a panini press grow
the [ __ ] up forget for a minute George
what's his name George Floyd forget that
for a second and just think about what
else has gone on in the past three
months the idea that the Brit you know
and I'm not for violence I don't want
anybody hurt and I don't want anybody's
private property [ __ ] with and I know
that that's what's coming and I know
that these riots they just you know
these violence begets violence but as an
observer to look back and to not realize
why this is happening and why that it
has a justification it means that you're
not paying any [ __ ] attention and
haven't been things ain't good damn good
I know they're good on Netflix I know
they're nice the TV shows you watch just
be nice just be nice out there don't
call anyone names well things are things
are much worse than that they're further
along the line they're further down the
line than just that there's a lot of
luxury problems we have in this country
and there's a lot of people that don't
have the luxury of having those problems
they don't have food their water is the
color of Nestle Quik and
cops have been putting your kids in jail
have been putting them in jail and I
mean listen
I mean I don't know what to tell you I
don't know to tell you but the whole
idea of like we're gonna do a beer
summit where Obama's gonna go down there
and have a beer with this cop and
forgive him and then the cops gonna go
on Ellen and do it
1970s style dance he's gonna or he's
gonna do some old depression-era big
bandy dance he's down there doing the
Charleston with Ellen it's not gonna
work anymore it's just not gonna work
people have had it I mean I don't know
what to tell you I'm sorry you know in
yes I would like to live in a world
where things aren't burning down and
there's not civil unrest in the streets
but I mean if anybody has been paying
attention to anything that has ever
happened even if you were paying
attention by accident you kind of get
where this has been going you get where
it's been going I don't really feel bad
for target I don't feel bad for autozone
I don't you know that police precinct
got burned because that and I love by
the way they just charged the cop we're
recording this Friday they just charged
the cop you know and you know people
like they they don't know what new
evidence the cop looked at the other DEA
looked at that made him charged the
comments like yeah the looting the
burning of the city made the Diego you
know what maybe we should like charge
the cop who did this and arrest him I
don't know maybe George Flo Floyd died
of coronavirus I don't know that's the
next thing you're gonna be a Cui's
tested positive for Kovan 19 I don't
know I'm unaware of what happened but
I'll tell you this the amount of people
out there defending target I find to be
laughable people should burn targets
down on the Reg on the regular burn
target down
gives a [ __ ] well.there its employees
the target yeah I'm sure they're upset
sure they're upset they can't go into
work at Target I'm sure there's a lot of
tears flowing right now for the
employees of Target that they can't go
to Target because it got torched you
know so that they don't have the honor
of working at Target and then leaving
and having a cop step is to stomp on
their throat on the way home from Target
you know why change that world it's been
working so well for everybody it is what
it is folks you know I'm not a proponent
of people getting hurt and I know it's
easy for me to say [ __ ] on Twitter cuz
I'm not out there throwing Molotov
cocktails you know but I mean what am I
supposed to sit and judge many people
who are and be like there are thugs and
animals it's like yeah dude cops don't
treat me the way they treat black people
I'll tell you that much they just don't
you know I did drugs I grew up on Long
Island me and my friends drove around
very wealthy areas we got high a lot we
drove around mansions smoking weed
seldom bothered by police you know
seldom pulled over I drove drunk a lot a
lot
hammered yes have I been pulled over yes
how's my license been suspended yes have
I had interactions and run-ins with cops
a hundred percent but you want to look
at the percentage of those versus the
percentage of law-abiding black I was
breaking the law law-abiding black
people have much higher percentages with
having incidents with police and they're
much more likely to be killed they're
much more likely to be taken into jail
and arrested so when people get angry
when this thing happens and then people
go out there and they set fire to places
because they are powerless they have no
power you've given them no power in
society they don't believe I mean dude
Epstein victims should be doing this
we're going to talk about that
documentary in a second but it's like
yeah these are chill
that were being [ __ ] on an island by a
guy who got away with it he got away
with it I mean the diluting should an
end in this country I mean I'm again not
that I want to see the results of it
none of us - but if you think logically
about it the brick should just keep
going through the windows really if you
think about it the amount of injustice
that you just have to swallow every day
but Wow all right I guess that guy hung
himself in the jail with the cameras on
and now all of the criminal sex
criminals pedophiles murderers
potentially they all can just none of
them will none of their lives will be
affected at all by this it's just neat
tidy guy killed himself that silver
there you go you know so the anger the
rage the builds in people it's just
[ __ ] it's real you know it's real I
threw him a griddle at someone today
it's room a griddle right in someone's
face because I want to be involved in an
in the limited capacity so I took him a
griddle and I just slapped someone right
across the face with a McGriddle and I
said no justice no peace and I walked
out okay because I want to be involved I
chucked him a griddle right he's
someone's grill unapologetically okay if
I go to a 7-eleven I see those red box
DVD things I'm gonna [ __ ] one of them up
if they're still there I don't know if
they are but if they are I'm gonna light
that up let's torch it let's torch it
why the [ __ ] not no justice no peace
I have you trusted my parents if anyone
wants to go over there wake them up I'll
be sharing that later on Twitter they
live in a wood house it'll go up easy
teach them a lesson
no justice no peace I have the addresses
of many people I feel have [ __ ] me
over in the business I should be bigger
I have their addresses
you go to their community stand outside
their homes wake them up show them
reality no justice no peace these are
just thoughts and ideas I'm an activist
you understand so if you would go to my
parents house and burn it down I'd be
very grateful and I think we could move
the country forward if you see my aunt
Kathleen out throw throw something at
her no justice no peace
if you see you're out on Facebook grab
or fall take or phone these are just
ideas these are just ideas because I'm
an activist and I want to I want to help
I want to help okay
that's all I think we could join the to
protest groups the people that want to
open everything up and the people that
want to burn everything down I have a
solution let's open it up let's eat and
then let's burn it down that is a
solution I can bring both sides of this
country together let's open it up let's
get it to stato nachos let's get it free
for all let's get a Jack Daniels whiskey
glazed chicken sandwich let's get a
brownie obsession and then when they say
here's to check oh no here's the check
and burn it the [ __ ] down
but let's have a meal first let's have a
meal and then let's bring it let's come
together now let's go in let's sit down
and then let's burn it down I have no
problem but let's get in there and let's
have a little let's have a salad with
some breadsticks low ranch dressing and
some bacon bets
we deserve it we went through a
quarantine let's open these places up
let's force them to serve us and then
let's torch them it's okay smack the
waitress with a fish sandwich not a
problem just tell her what it is out
there I'm an activist no justice no
peace
okay none of it's my fault but it's okay
I'm part of the problem I'll be part of
the solution
let's open up and let's burn down
Minneapolis looking like a third-world
country looking like a war zone it's bad
out there yes a lot of these protesters
are Looney Toons a lot of these
protesters are not what you would call
upstanding members of society many of
them and if I sat down with them we'd
probably not agree on a lot of things I
get it they probably want to abolish
private property capitalism the police
no you're gonna we're gonna have to have
a society I'm sorry we're gonna have to
have a society but if but but but in
between total apathy and burning
everything down in the middle of that we
can burn down the homes of my parents
and show people that they have to be
accountable for the decisions that are
made by their police in the district
attorney in between total apathy and
let's let's just end toll chaos we can
live in the middle by going and looking
at the list of names that I'm gonna put
on Twitter and waking them up guys I
want to talk to you about anvil rings
you know me I know a lot about jewelry
and jewels it's my business
anvil rings makes awesome handmade
jewelry in western Colorado and it's not
gonna break the bank
they've been handcrafting rings for
nearly ten years and take great pride in
the quality of their work and their
design they make rings from the
following unique materials these are
actually really cool meteorite meteorite
things that came from other places right
other planets in the solar system yeah
whiskey barrel that went from that went
from celestial to you know that's very
interesting but like we make rings from
many things moon rock
and cardboard meteorite risky whiskey
barrel ironwood natural shed elk oh
rogon love that and deer antler titanium
and tungsten carbide Damascus steel
black and acid-wash I do like that and
many more the rings are dreamt up made
and assembled in the USA over 500
five-star reviews every single purchase
includes free anvil ring silicone
activity band and an anvil rings faux
leather ring box which is cool cuz I'm
not harming any animals okay that's what
faux leather man
we offer free cisors discounted after a
ring purchase during this time to stay
safe and get sized at home so whether
you want a wedding band anniversary band
is just want a ring that looks awesome
head over to anvil rings here's a deal
guys promo code is TI m to get 20% off
your purchase right now a lot of people
are out of work they do not have the
disposable income that they once did but
you still want to commemorate things
that are happening in your life you
might still wanting to be you're getting
a wedding band out of her Surrey band
things like that these are still
important things and they're gonna
happen regardless of the economy
regardless of the amount of money you
have
so anvil rings is a great way to get a
cool ring made out of [ __ ] meteorite
how cool is that you're getting engaged
wanted you an anniversary band you know
commemorate how long you've been with
somebody you know maybe both on the
street doesn't matter you love each
other and you get a nice band you know
it doesn't really matter what what what
where you happen to be its anvil rings
dot-com and VI L are ing ask.com
promo code Tim you get 20% off a truly
unique ring it's cool looking if you're
not Boober rich you got to be cool this
is how it's been since the beginning of
time if you were rich you can just
lather yourself in diamonds or slather I
don't know what word I was going for in
any event slather as you slather a bread
with a sauce but lather
you lather the soap either one could
have worked diamonds but you you don't
have that you don't have that so you
need to do something cool and if you
have a cool ring that makes people go I
love that ring what is that it's go to
Facebook watch it's just a guy making a
table out of a tree and you watch it
because you appreciate the craftsmanship
and that's really what we're coming down
to it's gonna be what each craftsman you
appreciate it it comes from the nature
its materials that are from the earth or
the meteor um it's important to be able
to go and get these types of rings and
have them be cool they're not they don't
look or feel cheap at all in fact they
are artisan rings they're amazing but
you're not you're not spending thousands
of dollars you're spending hundreds of
dollars and you're getting something is
truly special unique distinct and you
can give it to somebody and be thrilled
about it and they're gonna be thrilled
about it too
so it's nice to give people things
people need things you are not enough
for the MS is really the reality
everyone's like well what about an
experience I just addicts but where the
what experience no concerts no
restaurant what experience you get to
get on a plane and what are you gonna
take a cruise it's none of it's
happening you've got to get him a thing
now the experiences are done for a
little bit you got to get him a thing
and the thing you want to get them as an
anvil ring does this have anything to do
with the anvil an ACME where you know
what i mean i don't i guess cuz they're
handcrafted so they're petty you know
how the anvil would fall on the who was
it or the coyote and the roadrunner they
had many problems right and it was a
quiz it whose were the roadrunner had
issues with who know that wily coyote
was always chasing the roadrunner he
never got caught but then there's
another bird that's starting with people
do you remember
Berta's it's a yellow bird tweety bird
but and that and what was an Tweety Bird
was having an issue with one of them as
well oh I didn't know that you know
nobody did you understand what I'm
saying yes I do though I'd I don't know
if you do other than Roadrunner and
coyote there were other issues on the
show that people had with each other
what was one of the other issues um
Elmer Fudd and Bugs Bunny they had a
problem big problem yeah and Daffy Duck
and Homer if I did what was to is Tweety
birds nemesis
so Sylvester the cat and didn't
Sylvester the cat get [ __ ] up and
Tweety Bird rose fly around it and
Sylvester like wake up yeah I think so
and Tweety Bird was [ __ ] up I think
with an end go to you Tennessee no see
if it's an anvil
if Tweety Bird ever got Sylvester with
an anvil because I I don't it's Tweety
Bird anvil I mean there's too much to go
through here but I'm imagining that it
happened do you see what I mean
yes Tweety Bird this is what I mean this
bird and the cat had massive issues yeah
the whole for the whole series they
hated each other
mm-hmm and the real anvil maybe was
coyote and the roadrunner
yeah but Tweety Bird would also do
diabolical things to the cat and the cat
and the cat deserved it right mm-hm
that's Tweety Bird giving the middle
finger I don't like that I think it's
for kids and I don't know why they're
doing that
my point is that people have struggles
in the world and you you you need to
commemorate what's going on with a
physical thing people like that you know
they don't just want an experience cuz
you can't give it to them right now you
actually have to get them a physical
thing my parents I don't think like
barely had wedding bands I think that's
why they got divorced
but anvil rings is a great way to do it
because you're not you're not walking
Harry Winston
well you're not walking at Harry Winston
now anyway because you can't go in there
but you're not walking into Cartier or
Bulgari or Tiffany's or Harry Winston or
really or van clefs and our pals are
really high-end jeweler why do I know
all these names cuz I know high-end
jewelers I know you know what I mean
I know conflict diamonds and mines in
Africa I know I know where the rocks are
the ices Jacob the jeweler in Lorraine
Schwartz I know the mole I have I have
connections in the game I wasn't I
literally I wrote on co-champs what I'm
saying is that you're not in that world
so you got to live in the world you're
in you're in a world of a cool ring
you're a cool person you don't have [ __ ]
but you're cool and what a cool person
could do is gonna [ __ ] domesticus
steel ring you look like a badass hop
off your bike and you get a Damascus
steel ring it's cool do you know what I
mean I'm gonna get the deer antler one I
think or maybe the elk antler I think
it'd look really cool yes yeah there are
many things to get what would the
roadrunner would drop the anvil on his
head you know any but that's the whole
thing's weird now anything about it the
roadrunner would run by and then the
wily coyote would try to kill him with
an anvil
yeah but somehow then while a coyote
would like get hit with the anvil like
he would he would always do the pain and
suffering it always end up happening to
while a coyote like you know I liked
gossamer the best yeah he was good the
big red guy he just he didn't he was
just what he was yeah you know what I
mean mm-hm you know he he he's just
living his life he was a big softy - was
he yeah he was like kind of sweet he was
also like a heinous monster right yeah
but he grew to love Bugs Bunny I
remember in one episode well somebody
would like to his nails and stuff yeah
yeah it was a great show that was a
phenomenal show it was a great it was
just a great Looney Tunes was a great
show and there was that cat oh now
that's skunk um was there skunk oh yeah
because the French skunk yeah yeah
Sylvester the cat was always trying to
have sex with Pepe LePew who was a
French skunk right odd
so Sylvester the cat would get a white
stripe then there was a Elmer Fudd yes
but then there was that other little man
who had the other little guy Marvin the
Martian no it was Elmer Fudd and then
who was that other that other hick Elmer
Fudd was bald who was that other hick
anvil rings folks you gotta get him
don't be stupid
um he was another guy I love the idea of
a ring I don't wear a lot of rags ISKCON
Yosemite Sam
Yosemite Sam Yosemite Sam he was one of
these open America up protests at
Yosemite Sam Tasmanian Devil that's you
know here's the point folks get
something that can be that can
commemorate special times in your life
and you're gonna have to get a ring and
it's it's not you're not gonna be able
to spend money on a diamond ring right
now it's irresponsible you should just
get a really cool-looking ring so if you
go to anvil rings calm a and V IL RI ng
s calm and use promo code Tim to get 20%
off a truly unique ring get something
cool if you want to do something nice
for somebody or for yourself you like
our show you want to support us this is
the place to do it it's cool to size
yourself for a ring I'm gonna maybe
start wearing a ring it's nice to have a
ring and this is kind of a cool one it's
a good conversation starter people say
hey what's that about what are you up to
and you say hey it's my [ __ ] ring
which one are you gonna get I think I'll
probably get a meteorite nice
why I have something from from the world
if I can have something from the space
right you know you know they could also
give me a rock what would I know I'd say
I was a meteorite yeah yeah yeah it
landed last night shut up um but I also
liked it Damascus steel the black an
acid-wash Damascus steel you know you'll
turn into you you get a ring like this
you start becoming a real man and
Galecki Game of Thrones to have a guy
start learning fencing be one of those
guys you know I thought you want to do
leather you know become become a man
actual man that's what this ring does
for you you become a man okay
anvil rings calm promo code Tim twenty
percent off a truly unique ring do it
folks you're not gonna regret it
yeah the epstein doc what did you expect
it was gonna be what did you think it
was gonna be
Bill Clinton confessing you think was
gonna happen he was gonna be just slain
max well she's on the thing like hello
here's my story it's light it is line
I'll bet Geoffrey we were both kids like
notes you know one thing I let me tell
you what my biggest takeaway from the
Epstein documentary on Netflix was men
Palm Beach is [ __ ] of legit you don't
see money like you do in Palm Beach
let's not forget that the East Coast
invented [ __ ] money let's not forget
it there are three places on this in
this world that you see mansions like
that and they are Long Island New York
the Gold Coast along Island where the
Vanderbilt to the Guggenheim's and all
those [ __ ] live Newport Rhode
Island and Palm Beach Florida makes Bel
Air and Beverly Hills look like [ __ ]
track houses I'm talking 50 room stone
castles marble beautiful that's the
takeaway you let's be honest you do not
feel as bad for the kids when you've
seen the homes what do you want to do
work at the gap shut
now I'm against the pedophilia in the
murder but let me tell you right now
it's a goddamn stunning estate it's a
beautiful property it's an iconic
property it's a nice place to be raped
not I am NOT for rape but if we went
down the list of places to be sexually
assaulted Palm Beach I mean the Frank
that scandal these kids are getting
sacrificed in barns and [ __ ] it's Omaha
they were eating at Waffle House's this
is pomf [ __ ] [ __ ] Beach private
islands ranches in New Mexico limestone
mansions right by Central Park in New
York City that's what you took away from
the there's nothing else there is I mean
you know the entirety of the story of
the entire documentary is it is is that
they divorce it from any historic
precedent of this happening before and
when the Vicky Ward is a journalist who
when I had Whitney Webb on the program
and if you watched a Whitney web show
you know that a lot of what you learned
in the Epstein doc you previously
learned on my show and more by the way
and don't get a twisted censorships not
all about not letting the information
come out this online censorship it's
about they want to triple it out and
they want to earn all the money off it
so don't kid yourself it's not only that
they don't want it to come out they want
it to come out in their [ __ ]
miniseries they want it to come out the
way they you know when they can profit
off it okay that's why when the F scene
story happens you know people go in to
buy the rights and these these mega
Hollywood guys get the rights to these
stories because then they're controlled
how the narrative is told to people and
the money you know so it's not just
about we don't want the info out a lot
of it is that but then some of its like
we're gonna have to put some of it out
if not all of it but we're gonna earn
the money from it
we don't want all these independent
people you know reaching audiences and
and building any type of equity in their
own operations online we want to control
the flow of information and capital to
us so the Epstein documentary you know
in the beginning Vicki Ward who's the
journalist we don't know if we trust I
don't know Whitney's very skeptical of
her I haven't done any research into it
it does smell a little fishy she wrote
an article about Epstein for Vanity Fair
Vanity Fair supposedly refused to
publish it but Vicki says in the
beginning she's like yep see was this
gabs be like man of mystery and so
automatically immediately in the
beginning of this series you go oh this
is a superhuman guy who's very
mysterious he's old it's oh he's a
once-in-a-lifetime figure he's just a
character with all these powers that we
don't know how he has any of them but
he's just this island so to speak no pun
intended unto himself which isn't true
okay les Wexner is mentioned briefly
it's like in a very in a very like
barely important way and les Wexler's
kind of portrayed as a victim this
billionaire is a victim of Jeffrey
Epstein this guy who owns Victoria's
Secret and limited and j.crew I believe
I'm not sure but he owns the first two
he's a billionaire the largest most
expensive residence in Ohio was a victim
of Jeffrey Epstein
he just got conned by this dictionary
salesman going door to door
Epstein just less Wexler just happened
to give him a mansion in Manhattan and a
ranch and all this money gave them
billions of dollars he got swindled by
Jeffrey Epstein supposedly swindled by
Jeffrey Epstein a college dropout from
New York City gets swindled well all
throughout the film we have to believe
that everybody's being swindled and
tricked and hustled and nobody has any
clue as to what's going on and Epstein
gets a job at Bear Stearns and they find
out he never went to school and I've
seen talks his way back into Bear
Stearns and okay maybe maybe not
No and he got this job at Dalton his
prep school in New York City in our
current Attorney General bar his father
I believe hired Jeffrey Epstein to teach
math at a prep school New York City one
of the top schools in the country Dalton
and and he got that job as a college
dropout and we're asked to believe that
all of these things and not one or two
of them but every single one is this
happenstance trickery that Jeffrey
Epstein is able to just move through all
these circles of people swindle them
take their money blackmail them
potentially we don't know but somehow
always come out of a shitstorm smelling
like you know lilies flowers he's fine
he's able to do that we're all supposed
to believe this and we don't talk about
any historical precedent for this
there's it none of it is mentioned the
Franklin scandal is not mentioned they
do not mention any thing about Jimmy
Savile who is a BBC presenter and a
heinous pedophile sick sadistic guy and
they don't go into any of this they
don't go into any of the credible
allegations about the kakora boys home
they don't go into any of it they don't
talk about the Catholic Church it's
pretty focused primarily on Epstein is
this man of mystery they don't talk
about blackmail operations having been
used before sexual blackmail underage
kids being used before no one brings
that up we're all supposed to just
believe that that Jeffrey Epstein just
exists on this cloud and he's floating
above everything and that somehow he's
able to make this sweetheart deal which
lets all of his accomplices named or
unnamed how insane is that you're not
even named just anyone that was involved
anyone that had their dick out on that
island you're good
that was the deal and we're supposed to
believe that he just you know he's just
lucked into that deal and it's just what
it is just locking charles Gasperi know
that geyser CNBC's the girl you'd always
in the poems its underfunded it's on the
fondue did other people to work there
they're not that bright you know who's
not that bright you you're not that
bright Charles because we both know
that's poor [ __ ] we know you could keep
somebody alive if you want to this was
the highest profile criminal in this
country you know in a long long long
time and the idea that like there was no
way to keep him alive he's just
completely insane you had cameras and
cells you know the guards were asleep
and the cameras weren't working
anybody believing the official story at
this point was in on it if you're on
social media go and I think that guy
killed himself you know whether you know
you're in on it you did it but that was
the Epstein documentary people wanted me
to comment on that there's nothing to
comment on truly there's beautiful real
estate if you like real estate as I do
many of you know of listen this program
I love real estate because many of the
people who've succeeded at it seemed to
be developmentally disabled and that
gives me hope when I watch these
television shows and I see the idiots
that are able to amass fortune selling
real estate I believe that I could
potentially have a second career real
estates a great fantasy career that I
could just sling homes to people but
that's all you're gonna get out of the
documentary the women that come forward
a brave they're they should be listened
to
it's heart-wrenching the types of girls
that they preyed upon our girls from
broken homes that had suffered abuse I
mean it's not it's worth a watch it's
well worth watching I'm telling you that
if it wasn't I would tell you but it's
not going to alter your perception of
the events there's no real new
information it's still worth watching
but it's not so in between you know
throwing a Molotov cocktail at Boston
Market
go and check it out it's nothing else
but to see Palm Beach it's beautiful but
that's really what it comes down to is
that you're not gonna get a real story
in any documentary you're not gonna get
the real story ever sorry you know what
the real story is you know it was a
blackmail operation people have secret
lives they are provided with illicit
substances drugs people streams of money
they're provided with these things and
they are to be controlled by people that
want to control them and one of the ways
you control people is by having damaging
potentially damaging information on
those people and that's what this is
it's not a huge mystery you know when
you start realizing that President
Clinton that was a governor of Arkansas
became the President of the United
States Arkansas you know at that point I
don't know what the population of
Arkansas was but you know I mean what's
the population of Arkansas now it's like
3 million so at that point it was
probably 1 million you know what I mean
like you know probably you know one and
a half two million people and then the
guy becomes a President of the United
States of America yeah it was 2.3
million in 1990 Arkansas one of the
smallest most inconsequential states in
the Union but he ends up the President
of the United States so you start
thinking about those things you know how
does that happen how does that happen
it's at an accident
it's an accident probably not you know I
mean it doesn't mean that everybody is a
pedophile it just means that you know
you have leverage on people you know
Obama became the president how did that
happen you know these men were talented
they were gifted they were driven they
had all of those things I'm not
suggesting that either one of them
wasn't didn't possess superhuman
abilities but
somebody's got to sign off somebody's
got to sign off somebody's got to loosen
the purse strings open up the vault and
give you all the money that's what
happens somebody's got to sign off does
it mean that these stars in Hollywood
aren't famous a lot of them are famous
but they got to get an opportunity
somebody's gotta you know open the door
you know you got to get that opportunity
and that's the same thing as politics
doesn't mean everybody gets it from
doing something illegal or shady but
that's certainly a possibility you know
and they end up in the political realm
certainly a possibility so it's well
worth a watch go check it out but we
know what the story is and we just so
talk about it every week you know I
think some of you were disappointed I
just don't talk about it every week it's
it's boring we know what it is let's
figure something else out you know what
it is we're against it I mean I don't
want to tell you it's like people who
look world you talk more about dual
court sports what do you want to say we
did it we know what it is we figured it
out I don't know day in and day out what
I'm supposed to do I don't even know why
people like you gotta have a take on
your team I mean yeah you hear it dad
you have it
I wasn't expecting from it I didn't get
anything out of it I mean that's the
take I mean guys you you you have to
start understanding there isn't going to
be a resolution here there's not going
to you guys think this is a television
show with a season finale
or a series finale and the it's boom
it's big it's Breaking Bad the last
night we all huddle on the couch
nothing's gonna stop me from watching
this I'm getting five accidents if I
have to and abandon my car [ __ ] my
family doesn't matter I'm getting in
front of that TV cause it's all coming
to the bill is coming to tonight the
justices sir it's not no it's a show
that goes on for too many seasons where
you go oh this is silly
yeah it's Alanna yeah I dunno
in them it's a soap opera that goes on
and on and on and when you start to look
at it like that you you just start you
get away a little bit you take a little
breather I you know I don't want to do a
show every week about the Epstein and
this one and then that one I I don't
want to break my brain many of you have
broken your brains you don't even know
it you think Donald Trump's tunnelling
under Central Park rescuing kids you
believe things of which there are no
evidence for I'll tell you what he's
doing we're and we're inching closer and
closer to a civil war and he's pouring
gasoline on that but you guys think he's
out there tunneling and helping children
and I'm so afraid of becoming one of you
I'm so afraid of having my brain broken
it's how I make a living I earn money
because I have a brain and I can speak
and I can understand and process things
you know some of you I just I get so
scared of becoming you I'm like what
happens just too many trips too many
trips to Reddit wherever you're going to
forums too many trips and I don't know
what happens but and it's easy it's easy
to break your brain I'm not the
healthiest eater it's not like I'm doing
like five miles a day in a canyon like
rogue and like my brain could easily
lose out of my ear and I could become
one of you like a bumbling lunatic like
a babbling psychopath muttering about
nonsense thinking that we were just one
week away enjoy the show yeah we will we
will enjoy the show [ __ ] lunatics I
don't know what to do I just know that
the people I know that became cops were
the same kids that were bullying
mentally [ __ ] people in my school
the same kids that were like bullying
and spitting on mentally but it's like
it's always that person who becomes a
cop when you're like oh you know
guy that used to spew remember the blind
girl you know the guy that used to spit
on her he's the sheriff
he's just sheriff now yeah used to spit
on that blind girl for no reason then
she tried to kill herself
I mean he's listen there's great cops
out there there's great police blah blah
blah whatever disclaimer you want and I
believe that I had uncle's there were
cops and you know they they somehow
didn't kill anyone or Becht and there
were no phones so let's just say Uncle
Eddie was one of the good ones there's
no evidence of that but let's just say
he was let's just say he was you know
what I mean he was just closed to fat I
don't think I ever got out of his car
and that helps people like the cops
shouldn't be fat they should be so fat
the cops should be the fattest people in
society so they can't do anything cops
should be 400 pounds minimum and just
drive around in [ __ ] little you know
on scooters like rascal scooter just a
morbidly obese police force of fat slobs
I hate everyone who's like why well the
cops aren't in shape that's why they're
shooting everyone they and it's like no
the cops shouldn't the cops should not
be able to get out of their car without
help they should have to be helped out
of their car
it grew up with these fake wrestling
moves where that's what they're trying
all these chokeholds out on people
because they grew up watching this on
WWF they think they're [ __ ] Hulk
Hogan and they're killing people in the
street you know that's what it comes
down to man I'm not saying all cops are
bad but let's be honest there's a lot of
[ __ ] uh there's a lot of cops out
there that are probably you know people
get in the game because they want to
play there's a lot of cops so let me
just say this let me just say this
there's a member of my family who's like
he's a good kid but he's like a what's
the name like an O right if you had a
name it would be like Biff you know what
I mean he's just a big oaf good heart
not a bad guy right but like in the in
the program to be a cop and you know
they got him for Christmas
they got him a shillelagh
phileas like an Irish stick for clubbing
people they got him an old and they got
him like an old I don't think it was a
shillelagh is like a gnarled piece of
wood but I think they got him like an
old nightstick and he was so happy with
it he was just walking around the house
like just you know we were all eating
cheesecake in the living room and then
you see this kid who's in his early 20s
in the hall pretending to be people with
the nightstick because he just wants to
get out and he just wants to you know
just stop beating people in their ribs
and he goes like this and his dad goes
just gonna come and herd through one day
he goes yeah yeah and he's swinging the
nightstick around
it's Christmas by the way gag the halls
with but he's swinging a nightstick
around cuz his perfect Christmas is that
he just wants to get out and me cap
somebody silent night he's waving the
[ __ ] night stick around he's not a
bad guy per se but what is that guy
gonna do in a high-pressure situation
what's that guy gonna do should we maybe
not lead with the nightstick and I'm not
saying we have to emasculate police and
I don't want to you know cities being
you know patrolled by improv troupes of
a [ __ ] testosterone [ __ ] deprived
parakeet you know you know emaciated
males but let's be honest do we do do we
just go right for the nightstick up
front and go here's here's here's a tool
to beat people yeah this guy tweets I
don't know if this was a troll or not he
goes this is Alex parenting I forget
what he used to run used to run a big
site he's still mine because they can't
be reformed to span the MPD it's a
Minneapolis Police Department and every
other big urban Police Department hire
some detectives to investigate the
serious crimes with actual victims and
social workers and civil servants for
the other duties pay local bar bouncers
and auntie fuh to patrol neighborhoods
and I quote tweeted that and I said this
is why the Republican Party indoors that
type of tween right there
tweeted that Donald Trump jr. what is
that no one thinks that's the answer
here but I don't know if the thing you
do is to hand somebody a [ __ ] club I
mean when I say this kid was waving
around the nightstick like like like
imagine Star Wars without the force like
it just the lightsaber and there is no
force to guide you and who gives a [ __ ]
there is no light and darkness just
hears the lightsaber and goes zap a few
[ __ ] that look at you the wrong
way that's kind of what this feels like
Ridgewell it mm-hmm
you want a wallet right now folk so you
you sanitize easily you want a wallet
right now that you can use as a weapon
you want a wallet right now
you could cut someone's throat with if
you have to you want a wallet right now
that you can you can fit in a small
place you want a wallet right now that
you could conceal in a body cavity if
you're being arrested by the police
Ridge wallet does all of these things
it's a minimal front pocket wallet
that's designed to streamline what do
you carry every day that's a thirty
thousand five star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash and cards
there's a lifetime warranty if you love
it and free returns if you don't I have
one Ben has one it comes to titanium
carbon fiber aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors okay rage
calm slash Tim tea I am okay
you know what 10% off your purchase free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to Ridge comm slash Tim promo code t IM
link is in the description of this
episode the ridge wallet is a great
wallet because it's perfect for the
times that we're living in right now
civil war pandemic collapse a civil
society not a problem Ridge wallet I
mean who cares you have to fight your
own family soon your own friends have to
fight them over for resources you think
you're gonna you're gonna worry about a
why in a little while you know nice
little wallet because you're going to be
blood from your brother in the street
right now that's where we're at in this
country the entire social order is
collapsing you know and it's a rotten
system it's gotten even worse and it's
gotten you know truly unsustainable and
people are are taking to the streets and
there's fires and riots at the smashing
of glass and you know civil society will
be you know probably a quaint idea
pretty soon we're all just gonna be out
in the street you know I mean it's gonna
be messy sloppy
you know bloodletting really that's what
it's gonna be and you know it's gonna
pit family members against each other
and best friends in the streets just you
know fighting determining the future of
this country and it's you know you're
gonna see climate change and famines and
all kinds of problems that already
compound our social upheaval you know
our uneasiness or racial and class
problems all inflamed you know the
beating hot Sun you know all of these
problems you know leading to this just
chaotic massive you know episode that is
going to probably result in like some
crazy you know National Guard military
in the street you know you know partial
collapse of society and when all of that
happens not if when all of it happens
you're gonna feel a hell of a lot better
with a ridge wallet in the front pocket
of your genes that are also stained with
the blood of your family and this isn't
a you know I'm not lying about any of
this ish it's [ __ ] common it is what
it is this is this is phenomenal this is
just strawberry and coconut water sorbet
well the reality is I mean you're gonna
have to decide who to kill who to eat
and you don't want to have a leather
wallet you want something sleek that can
fit this is all happening I mean I don't
know what to tell you you want me to
like be like hey Ridge well it's cool
when you go on a date and you pull it
out lady's gonna be like hey what's that
that that type of marketing's over we're
in the end now okay
or nyan now cars lit on fire overturned
the screams of strangers in the night
that's what you will fall asleep to the
screams of people you don't know and you
will pray that they don't become your
screams and they will and so that said
against the backdrop of that you get a
ridge wallet Ridge is cool because you
and your buddies can no no no death and
gas doesn't gas to the gas it's what it
is I'm not I didn't do it but it's gonna
happen so I'm not gonna market anything
on the show anymore like some [ __ ]
goofball I'm marketing for for the real
world that we're gonna be living in
which is you're going to be in a
paramilitary group whether you like it
or not you'll probably live in a quad
room you know um and you know you'll
fight other paramilitary groups for
resources and I imagine this is after
the government Falls after the nuclear
war in the nuclear winter when there is
no there's no real commerce anymore
there's no money system the money system
will collapse so that's why it's good to
have a Ridge wallet even though you're
saying yourself well I won't even need
money or cards if the money system
collapse it's still fun to have it's
I'll it's a sleek little thing it's a
weapon really is a weapon essentially
it's a weapon by it is a weapon don't
even buy it is him you'll still need
certain things to remind you of who you
are so even though the credit cards
aren't gonna work after the money says
I'm collapse you're not going to
remember your name because you're gonna
be through so much trauma and you might
have concussions and things like that to
just you might not be able to even read
anymore but you just kind of to feel
your name that's slightly raised on the
card because you will have been blinded
by a chemical that sprayed at you by the
police so by having these cards handy
you'll be able to figure out your name
again you understand even though the
money system is not gonna work you'll
need things to barter with and you know
the idea that you can just remember your
name by taking out your wallet and
saying oh who
because you're gonna wake up in a forest
you'll be wandering around this empty
mall there'll be nobody there you know
you'll just see a bear off in the
distance and you know some zombie trying
to get out from under a car but then the
car will collapse on them I mean it's
it's post-apocalyptic horror show and
then you take your wallet I think Oh Who
am I Who am I and then you go oh I'm
John Belushi no mm-hmm I mean he's worth
it right there is in folks and it's
worth it right there you know ridge comm
/ti em that's ridge comm /g I am yours
use promo code Tim to get 10% off in
free worldwide shipping is you need
identification you need to remind
yourself and your friends who you are
you might might encounter hostile people
and you might have to prove to them who
you are look this is me this is who I am
I'm real I mean that's where we're
headed so I mean I'm not gonna be like
you know it's cool better Ridge while it
is when you're at the beach and you know
no you awaken you awaken under a bridge
and you don't know who you are and you
reach in your pocket for something and
you're gonna be glad to pull out the
ridge because you don't remember but you
got you took cover because there were
Rockets they were mortaring a group of
anti-government people that you were a
part of and you you found you even
though there's a lot of mortars that
went off right by you and you got
shocked shell-shocked you found your way
back under a bridge and you slept there
and you woke up now you know you're kind
of like trying to figure out who you are
you have a little bit of amnesia and you
pull out the ridge wallet and then you
can just go you know join whoever's left
of the anti-government people and again
set about the work of creating a new
society based on shared principles a
common good whatsoever so on and so
forth and get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping okay rage calm /ti em
rage calm /ti em link in description
good luck out there
I wanted to address obsess simons oh
well shouldn't give any more press
failed bird poet cultural critic clown
critic the who criticizes pounds
revolutionary Seth Simons without
without tagging me of course I went at
me on Twitter because of my defense or
not really a defensive Jimmy Fallon
doing blackface but when I said listen
you know some things are appropriate at
certain times some things are not and it
was about the the sketch that resurfaced
with Jimmy Fallon you know playing think
it was Chris Rock on SNL yeah and so
Jimmy Fallon writes in 2000 while on SNL
I made a terrible decision to do an
impersonation of Chris Rock while in
blackface there's no excuse for this
blah blah blah thank you for holding me
accountable so I rode I wrote this thank
you for all thank you all for holding me
accountable which is what Fallon said
and I said is such an insane statement
it is think about that think about that
thank you all for holding me accountable
it's such an insane statement never
capitulate to a mob I've said this
before about mobs
sometimes a mob is right it's still a
mop do you get it you know so when you
capitulate to a mob and now you either
say well what about the mobs on the
street burn and down to target here's
what it I'm not saying all those people
are right about whatever they believe in
but I'm saying they're angry and that
anger is justified the anger Jimmy
Fallon doing blackface isn't real no one
really cares that's a big difference
there
the anger here is real no one watches
the Fallon doing blackface feels any
similarities to watching this guy get
his life taken away on [ __ ] camera by
so there's no comparison but I wrote
never capitulated to a mob [ __ ] these
people times change
what's appropriate changes that's true
and I wrote this isn't about that it's
about dragging someone because it's the
only way to feel powerful obviously we
need a second wave a second wave of
coronavirus my little joke at the end
which a lot of Seth Simon's because he
writes about comedy doesn't understand
comedy at all and none of the none of
the I think 9,000 people who follow him
his wide reach none of those people
understand comedy either because a lot
of them were like oh yeah eight not even
eight thousand seven hundred great so a
lot of those people were like um are you
on my Twitter right now I'm logged into
mine okay okay interesting so he uh he
quote tweets me but doesn't quote we me
doesn't tag me this is what these people
do by the way they talk endless [ __ ]
about you on Twitter and then none of
them tagged you none of them want a
response they want to this is what they
love canceling people and dragging
people because they don't want and
that's where they love t platforming cuz
no one can respond to what they say
about I don't care people make videos
I'm fat I'm grown I don't care what
anyone does about me I'm only addressing
this because it's an interesting
conversation to have but most of the
things I find them funny I don't it
doesn't bother me I make a good living
being funny and if other people want to
talk [ __ ] about me how am I I'm not
gonna hate on them I don't respect them
I don't respect all those people out
there
I respect people I feel have talent but
it doesn't matter I'm not gonna go at
you and say you shouldn't have a
platform who gives a [ __ ] you want to
call me fat to N I do it you can do it I
mean what do you want to do what am I
supposed to take you to court show up be
like your honor yeah see alright like I
can't even breathe oh my god
I'm all the ways and Ray comes defending
me he's there like your honor listen man
you see my client is a beautiful man
little I will garrus garrus success
simons goes the wealthiest people in
show business should never have to
answer to anyone this is Seth's attempt
at sarcasm Seth again not great
well these people in show business
should never have to answer to anyone
blackface was appropriate in 2000 people
who upset about it aren't actually upset
about it Jesus here's the reality
blackface was done frequently by lots of
people and people laughed at it and it
was now was it appropriate in the sense
that like was it ever morally true who
the [ __ ] you know who knows but the idea
that it wasn't done white people dressed
up as characters that were black and
imitated them you know when now looking
at that you go oh yeah that wasn't great
but to say that in the year 2000 then it
was like some deep deeply offensive
thing in the context of the time it
wasn't and I can prove it wasn't because
it was done on a mainstream show and no
one cared
black people you know might have been
upset about it maybe they didn't have
the platform to talk about it but the
reality was it wasn't like this shocking
thing in the so when I say times change
the word [ __ ] was appropriate at a
certain point and not that it was ever
correct
it wasn't moral never calling a gay guy
a [ __ ] it was never moral but using the
word in your lexicon of words that you
used at one point was appropriate most
people don't use that word most people I
know don't use that word all the time
now because what is appropriate changes
just changes pippy's to be like that's
gay all the time people used to be like
okay most people don't do that anymore
things evolved and the people that are
still doing that are just holding on to
these things and they're dinosaurs they
won't involve they won't make any money
and they're just going to be there dudes
good
they want to hold on to that you want to
hold on to saying the word goop or
whatever you want to you know forever or
some other offensive thing or doing an
Asian accent fine do it
I might laugh at it I might think it's
funny but the vast majority of people
coming up in the world right now it's
hack it's over it's been done find new
ways to make people laugh that doesn't
mean you gotta go film the net but it
means you evolve okay but this guy
paints me like a Charlotte's Film Archer
because I have said that I think it's a
little you know the the priorities are
odd to me digging up old SNL skits in a
country where 30 million people are out
of work in the last three months nobody
has any [ __ ] health insurance the
cops are murdering people the cities are
literally burning which this guy is
tweeting nothing about he's focused on
Jimmy Fallon's 2000 SNL slate of
sketches um I tweeted it's ridiculous so
then he goes B goes down in the article
and he goes this guy meaning yours truly
this guy pays the left enough lip
service that I think a lot of people
miss where his sympathies actually lie
because I pay the left a lot of lip
service okay um my sympathies lie with
humor my job is to be funny my opinions
really don't matter and I'm truly
telling you this they don't matter I
share them with you anyway I share them
anyway some of them are funny some of
them are not some of them are correct
some of them might not be but they're
not my jaws on my job my job is to be
funny and to process things that are
happening in real time because I have
talent I have actual talent Seth does
not have any talent it's just and and I
I'm sorry about that
I would love a bigger penis I would like
a six-pack I want a little bit more
melanin in my skin so that it doesn't
blister and boil like a disgusting Irish
piece of [ __ ] I want a lot of things one
thing I have is talent one thing Seth
does really not have his time I
apologize that you were given none of
this
than I possess that I've worked pretty
hard to to acquire so he says that I pay
the the left lip service I pay everyone
lip service in the sense it like all I
do is flap my [ __ ] lips that's my job
dummy just so it's like it's like me
saying he pays the the left
he pays comedy finger service cuz he's
just typing all the time right but where
my sympathies actually lie I thought
Sanders would have been a great
candidate what would have been a great
president I don't know what it could he
have gotten anything done I don't know
but he would have been a great candidate
I think people should have health
insurance
I don't think health insurance should be
a business but again I'm not a Marxist I
believe in private property private
ownership private business I believe you
should be able to lock your wet self
away from society as long as you pay
your taxes you follow the law and [ __ ]
like that
I believe you shouldn't have a secret
government of you know dark money
pedophiles running around the world
starting Wars to enrich themselves and
their friends
I don't know draw a line around those
positions and come up with a party and
I'm that that's what I believe
draw a line around that and come up with
that I I would I would prefer if dark
money billionaires didn't arrange wars
all over the planet impoverished vast
amounts of people rape torture murder
censor destroy everything that was good
I'd rather everything not be
corporatized and turned into an
advertisement for chase
I like independence and autonomy I think
I want to live in a Stanhope Ian future
where we all have little homes in Bisbee
Arizona and little bingos and dogs and
cats that seem to die and that somehow
never do and then just I mean IIIi don't
know but I said of Ron Bennington today
why both Rob Bennington is the best
broadcaster in the country hands down by
the way he's my favorite person the
broadcast if you don't listen to
Bennington you're an idiot
I grew up listening to Bennington I
listen to him constantly he has a better
take on most things than most people
I've been listening to him since I'm 14
years old
and I called him to a show today which
is an honor to do to talk to the guy and
that's why everybody oh you
this celebrity in that celebrity being
able to call in around Bennington and
perform around Bennington means more to
me than any of these [ __ ] people um
that I that I did I see or be there in
LA or the Comedy Store with Channing
Tatum Diggs you're funny who gives a
[ __ ]
is he gonna face [ __ ] me later probably
not so the reality is but I was talking
about it in today and I was describing
what I think the world was gonna look
like it he goes he goes most people
describe a world where they would they
they're gonna participate in it he goes
this is not a world for you I said not
at all the world that's coming will not
be a world for me and that's okay I'll
I'll perch myself on the outside of it
and do what I have to do because the
world that's coming is a world where the
Internet's flattened everybody
individuality is just not going to
matter as much as it can't it can't it
just won't I'm not telling you right or
wrong I'm telling you what's gonna
happen
people have been flattened their
formative experiences some are rich and
poor and there's vast differences in the
way that people grow up and and the
level of privilege they have or whatever
but because everything is online
many of these people's formative
experiences and cultural interactions
are very similar so you know when you go
out to dinner with people it's hard now
to find a real character
just what I was telling Bennington like
a real character where it's like you
know the expression used to be like what
were you raised in a barn who is this
guy who is this person somebody that was
just a thumb their nose at every social
convention that came from nowhere that
got off some bus and you're like what
the [ __ ] is this prayer you're gonna see
a lot less of that because everybody's
been flattened it's gonna get boring but
maybe it'll be better maybe the
individuality you know and and again I
don't care I have no I have no say in
which way it goes but maybe with a lot
of that individuality came uncertainty
and risk and you know there's you know
Jeffrey Epstein was an individual you
know can't say he wasn't so the reality
is the future that's coming is not a
future that I'll feel terribly
comfortable in but that's why I do the
job I do because I can kind of perch
myself on the outside of it
so Seth does this think
so what's interesting is in the thread
this is something I didn't realize was
gonna happen somebody posted a reddit
thing from Chris Gethard and this kind
of struck me as odd because Chris
Gethard was a friend of mine I I don't
hate Chris Gethard but I thought this
was very strange that this was done and
I and I will read this comment this was
a Chris Gethard answered one of his fans
on reddit who I guess asked why the
election night special that I filmed
with Ray Kampf and Chris did not air me
and look at this somebody somebody
somebody comments I love it they go he
said blackface was appropriate in 2000
shaking my head well where were you in
2000 I mean it's like I didn't say I
wasn't doing it in the year 2000 I was
doing cocaine and selling subprime
mortgages I wasn't a [ __ ] loser I
didn't do that to 2004 doesn't matter
the point is that so Chris Gethard
writes this thing which I fight and I'll
read it to you and I found this to be a
little disappointing and I'll go into it
I'm not gonna make a huge thing out of
it so this again somebody asked where
this election special was and and if you
know anything about me and Ray in the
show the election special with Chris
Gethard to send it into chaos to send it
into a hellscape why because me and Ray
were brought in now picture this Chris
Gethard is an improv comic who does
stand-up he's more of a storyteller he
had a show for many years me and him
shared the same manager Chris introduced
me to the manager I would go on the road
with Chris Chris is a very creative guy
he's um um you know very open and honest
about his struggles with mental illness
and things like that you know I always
used to kid around like how mentally
elizy cuz my mother has really
schizophrenia but you know she's not you
know in Rolling Stone you know she
doesn't have an HBO special you know but
I'm not saying it he doesn't suffer from
it I'm sure he does I'm just saying
there are levels you know so many of his
much of his fanbase also struggles with
mental illness let's be honest I used to
open for him they come they sit on the
floor they said
indian-style you know it's in every show
you feel like you're performing in a
rehab and that's okay but that's what it
is right and he lives in kind of this
terror of being cancelled by them
because that's his bread and butter
that's where he makes his money and I
understand that so a lot of these fans
are not in love with yours truly and
they they were at one point they have to
Donald Trump won the election these
people then decided that anyone that
wasn't going to tweet 20 times a day
about how insane it was and that we were
now living in hell and as a white guy
I'm supposed to go on Twitter every day
and be more offended and more effective
than minorities which is what I found
ridiculous
so me and Ray Lewis will pick for this
and I've told this story before on the
show but we're telling it again because
I was kind of shocked by this comment a
little shocked man um me and Ray show up
because they said us you know again I
used to write these long screams on
Facebook that were very funny I had no
money I was making $15 an hour not even
as a tour guide in New York City for 40
hours of work does about two hundred and
eighty dollars after taxes and
everything it's horrible which is why
I've always said working people get
[ __ ] right now I'm doing that I make
tips I may maybe make fifty $100 a day
cash tips but you know me I got dinner
and it's over right so I should have you
know but I had enough money to survive
but I was like not making any money but
I write these long screeds about like
defending billionaires and it was
hilarious you know and how people didn't
deserve money and everything was very
very funny and it was all very very
funny and everyone thought it was funny
cuz it was very funny was it political
they're not pulling a butt tour guide
talking about you know mansions and
homes and and they're all on a tumblr
I'll share them whatever none of them
are political
um and then occasion I'd poke holes in
like something like when people would be
like say something political that was
always far to the left
I would always challenge it right same
way if somebody's far to the right yeah
I would chat I would just challenge
things to poke holes in things and that
was all okay up until Donald Trump won
the election and at that point people
were like oh my god this is
dangerous this rhetoric is dark you're
part of the problem is people like you
that got Donald Trump elected it's
people like you that are the reason
things are blah blah blah and it was
like it was like I was like stunned by
like the about-face turned in a lot of
these people made not really I wasn't
affected so much but like just look at
what comedy then went through after the
election people are coming after
comedians canceling people and it became
this political battleground that it had
never been and I'm not gonna ignore him
talk about it because we all know what
it was like in every podcast was full of
these discussions and debates you know
about PC culture and all this [ __ ]
so Chris called me and he goes I want
you to come election night I'm doing a
show and I'm doing a show on election
night and I want you and Ray Kampf to
show up because Hilary's gonna win and
you guys are gonna be like the heels and
it's gonna be hilarious to have you guys
come in and be like these we were never
Trump supporters neither one of us cares
I mean it's like I didn't care I mean
now I mean with the cities burning it's
like yeah but a lot led up to Trump I
don't I don't think Trump's good for the
country yet in the same way that I
wouldn't have Caitlyn Jenner be the
president or anyone I know primarily
from my television set right so so he
calls me up and he goes come by you and
you and I forget the way he worded it
but he's like you and Comp are gonna be
the like you're gonna deliver like this
hard-edged realism I'm gonna read he was
commenting he describes it better he's
more eloquent about this particular what
he wanted out of this night so me and
come come in barging in and you know
dialing it up being me and come to fat
loud guys on a set with a bunch of very
very liberal very left-wing improv
comedy people there's a guy next to me
dressed like a banana you get it there's
a lot of white women we know how great
they are so it's it's all these people
some of them are very talented right
were talented so it's just me and Ray
doing exactly what we were told to do
which is to come in and be bombastic and
you know like Ray's eating these cheese
balls and I'm just kind of going off and
just being funny saying everything I can
to be funny at one point a girl stands
up and she starts going I'm just so
worried Trump wins and I'm like wait
wait where you grow up let's get real
cuz could tell she was a rich kid and I
was just doing crowd work with her like
hey let's be honest where did you live
what is your father
you know her father's brother CEO Boeing
you know it's worried about Trump so
pointing out that hypocrisy was fun so
now this was this was funny for the very
beginning right now even in the very
beginning things weren't breaking the
way that everyone thought they were
gonna break but there was still a lot of
hope so in the beginning it was it was
happening the way that everyone wanted
Tim and Ray are they're they're being
bombastic they're being funny and as the
night wore on it got less funny and
we're weren't hard to be funny right now
everybody else has decided to you know
they're upset or they're upset I'm not
upset I'm on the front of my phone true
Michael whose it s now everyone else
crying they're all crying and I'm like I
call drew that's what me and drew were
like best friends and I called he called
me and he's like snickering laughing and
he's like you know here's why we all
thought it was funny not because anyone
loved Trump but because the idea that
like all of these liberals were like so
confident you ever have a friend that's
so confident they're gonna [ __ ] this
chick or this dude or whatever it is and
then for whatever reason they just get
shut down and it's hilarious because it
just shuts them down and and these are
people that have just been eight years
of Obama drone striking people and you
know financial crime going on knowing it
you know and they don't care cuz Obama's
on Ellen or whatever so it's just this
neoliberal like Yas Queen stops lay
[ __ ] and like all of it you know every
argument fillery Clinton's candidacy was
faulty I have
only good one I was the only Hillary uh
advocate of her and I did advocate for I
said give her the job because she's a
murderer
that's and I said she should win because
she's a murderer and she's just get like
it's just cuz I knew now I didn't vote
for I didn't vote for anyone but I knew
that Trump was going to inspire this
cult-like devotion of people who think
that he's doing any something he's not
gonna do anything right I know people
that like know him from New York I know
like not to say that super inside
whatever but like the guy easy he
doesn't what do you what do you think's
happening here so I knew that like this
guy was just the revolution wasn't
coming and then I also I made the only
good argument failure Clint which was a
hilarious argument which was it she was
an old crook and a murderer and you
should just give her the job it's one of
my jokes I say in stand-up I said when
you kill enough people you should just
get the job of President they should
just make a serial killer the president
because that's all you have to do is
just kill large swaths of people and
then go eat chicken Barbra Jean that's a
job you eat you kill if you do my
country and then you go to the residence
and you go good this Brussels sprouts
are good now that's just what it is
right or wrong good or bad more that's
what it is and it's funny to point those
things out that's funny I didn't create
the system but when you put it out cuz
it's what you would talk to your friends
about you'd smoke a joint your backyard
you know here's what I think this thing
is I'm just killing a bunch of people
and eating dinner it's what it is
and Hillary can she can certainly do
that so they are all starting to get
really upset and they start yelling at
me because I'm not upset they start to
like police my emotions you know to use
a [ __ ] Twitter [ __ ] term and I
just start laughing in their face
nothing makes someone angrier then when
you laugh in their face I hate it when
you laugh in someone's face unless it's
you know it's my job you have to laugh
in my face I'm a comedian when you so
they're they're like crying so
throwing themselves on the floor a
banana is sitting next to me and he's
crying
someone is dressed like a banana and
they're crying how do you not laugh now
I'm dead serious
how do you not laugh at a banana in
tears next to you yeah because this is
what Chris would deal would be like I'm
helping all these young comics by having
them dress up like fruit and sit on the
set of my show fine great whatever you
want to do you know that's how we would
help people ego you're gonna be a grape
some guy would sit during a grape suit
and he'd be like that's Gary the grape
you know whatever hey I'm not judging
but so somebody asked him why this
episode wasn't released crisco's we
would have released it if it was as
simple as the party I don't like one
unfortunately the timing of everything
made things bad creatively and morally
for me not as an individual but as a
creator of a community of creative
people this is when we start realizing
that this is a call when you start
saying things like as the creator of a
community of creative people like you
are there you secure there I'm like
you're going to curate all of their
experiences you have to shield them from
certain things you have to protect them
you are their father you gave birth to
them this is language that I've always
felt very weird sort of uncomfortable
with this type of language uhm the
obvious bit was that Hillary was gonna
win and Tim would come on to be our
splash of water in the face bringing
things back to reality in the very funny
way he was so good at back then da da da
da da back then right cuz I'm so
different now than I was at all so to
get this out of the way and I don't want
to dive deep into it although it's a 7
paragraph thing on reddit
I don't want to dive deep into what 2016
Tim was a friend of mine in a creative
allied mine I don't know that's is true
in 2020
so keep the contacts in mind that he's
grown in ways it separated us I've seen
Chris since I saw him at a wedding
we were very nice to each other he
brought his baby to the wedding which
you don't do and everyone at the wedding
was offended by the
it's a very de classe move to bring your
baby to a wedding your newborn to a
wedding you either leave someone home
with it or you leave it with family or
you have someone want but you don't
bring your newborn baby to a wedding
which was absurd but I don't blame him
because he's a sweet guy but he's not a
Kennedy so he doesn't like you know the
rules of decorum are not you know I get
it it is what it is you just don't show
up with a baby in a playpen is this not
what it is okay
but I saw him at the wedding he's a
sweet guy I like his wife he's talented
I'm not [ __ ] on him at all I was I
was kind of shocked by this comment was
it was strange to me so he goes I don't
know that so he goes instead of the plan
five that his bit would have created
things broke how they did and he stick
took a much darker turn it came off even
darker and more aggressive than it
usually did he looked bad for it I
looked bad for showing up and doing what
I was asked to do which was be a
comedian on a comedy show that was
taking place during election night where
there were two potential winners one of
them who've who won so I look bad for
being asked to do or for doing what I
was asked to do I can't believe he's
responding to reddit comments by the way
this is shocking to me that he responded
to torretta comments like this
I was completely shell-shocked with the
results after twelve hours of being on
camera and physically and mentally shut
down for a few minutes and lost control
of the show now who was one of my
dearest friends got into a shouting
match with Tim which I think I enjoyed
and I think she did do neither looked
good there were a few female performers
on camera at the time who wound up in a
battle with Tim over the tenor of his
comments in relation to Hillary being
female by the way I was calling Hillary
a murderer all night and they objected
that I had mentioned she was a woman
again so before he had finished his
thoughts and found the comedic twist on
them which is fair chris is being fair
to me there's trying to be funny those
performers didn't look good a few
audience members jumped up and grabbed
Mike's who express their emotions they
had very good points but ultimately they
did not good then afterwards comedy was
still scheduled to happen and it was not
a fair environment to stage comedy in
and none of these performers looked good
[Music]
here's the reality you know I pity
people that live in constant fear of
being canceled I don't live in concert
here being canceled I haven't set up my
career like that
I have not arranged my career in a
manner that gives people the power over
my career other than my fans people
listen to the show and the people that
buy ticket to see me live I feel bad for
people who don't know whether Chris is
in that situation or not I believe he is
and some of that's not his fault some of
it is just he came up at a time where
you needed you know and even though
Chris is you know independent of the
business to an extent he does a lot of
things on public access I still feel
like he's terrified of his fan base
because they're not mentally well a lot
of these people that he's you know it's
not only about comedy it's comedy plus
comedy plus mental illness so I mean he
used to show me he gets calls and texts
and emails people threatening to kill
themself I'm een it's a very tough thing
when you make yourself of that so I
understand he wants to protect people
and whatever but to say that I was a
creative collaborator and a friend of
his and now I've grown in ways that have
separated us I certainly have grown a
ways that have separated him but like
the idea that like I am that my schtick
is somehow different now than it was or
that I am some type of dangerous or dark
I still respect Chris they still think
he's funny I had shank Gillis on my show
Shane had said something about Chris on
his podcast which got reported by one of
these scumbags who wrote articles about
Shane and I brought up Chris and I
didn't say that Chris was a friend I
just said and you had a thing with Chris
Gethard and Chris got very angry with me
he's like why wouldn't you say that we
were friends by the way this is recently
when did I Shane on God that was in
November right yeah so this is not like
a long time Innes is pretty recently
Chris was angry that I didn't present it
like we were friendly you know and I
didn't even realize that I was like
sorry Chris I wasn't even thinking you
know I respect you blah blah blah but
you know I I wasn't thinking like that
so he at that point he was but now he's
kind of like on reddit he's like well
he's grown in ways that have separated
out and he was good and when he said
that he was like he was really good at
that back then the type of comedy he did
he was really good
at it back then and it's like nothing's
different you changed your audience
changed what they wanted out of comedy
changed and I've been consistent the
whole way through I'm here to make you
[ __ ] laugh I'm here to entertain you
so to me to write this entire threat and
again you know all of this is done so
that I can't respond all of this is is
written in a way outside of the public
view so that I don't have anything to
say so that I look like some crazy
right-wing lunatic or whatever I don't
care how I look but like it's just funny
to me make a public statement about it
I'm fine like that's totally cool put it
on Instagram put it on Facebook say
somebody wanted to know why this wasn't
released here's what it is but to put it
on on on reddit and just having somebody
send it to me where this guy's going
like yeah Tim was really good back then
at comedy but now he's grown in ways
that I don't really I support and it's
like it's it's kind of a cowardly thing
to do he also took down the video
I did a very funny video on a show um
where I was telling people not to vote
and to marry for money it was very funny
he yanked it off YouTube because he said
that the black kid in it Justin was
getting harassed by some alt-right troll
which was kind of hilarious is like what
does somebody send him a DM i man so
here's my problem it it's not I don't
have a [ __ ] talking fast here and [ __ ]
this and [ __ ] Chris or whatever because
I don't feel like that I think Chris the
creative unique guy that lives in fear
of his fanbase turning on him and then
that is a massive that's a massive issue
um and and I just want to say I like
Chris and whatever and I have no problem
with him and if he doesn't like me
because Trump won an election that's
okay and I feel that saddens me because
I'm still doing the same County Chris
has helped people he's he's made he's
given funny people a platform whatever
he gave me a platform and I'm grateful
for that and I respect that but if
you're gonna ask me to go on a show and
not think it's
funny that a guy dressed like a bananas
crying I I can't help you I don't know
what to tell you you know so we're gonna
wrap it up like this god bless everybody
be nice just be nice
what do you have to do out there other
than just be [ __ ] nice that's the
only thing you should do in this planet
just be nice if you see somebody that's
frowning strap on their throat now I
mean listen I'll tell you this folks
Epstein Doc's well worth watch sorry the
Chris Gethard I
I mean I would love to release cuz yes
nobody looked good he's right nobody
looked good that is comedy it's actually
probably very funny it's actually
probably great and unfortunately it
won't see the light of day which is okay
but I would have I would have preferred
that somebody make comments about me in
a public forum or be honest with me or
have a conversation with me and not
write a 7 paragraph thing on Reddit and
and you know try to distance himself
from me as much as possible um it's ok I
mean it is what it is you know I've
always wanted to entertain real people I
don't I don't ever you know I I just you
know so I'm not super concerned with
like uh you know the comedian's that I
like respect me you know the guys that I
really respect and girls I really
respect they respect me but I just find
that you know this is just advice for
anyone in any creative field don't build
a castle made of like cancelable sand
like don't be terrified because me Chris
did funny [ __ ] together and then to pull
it off YouTube and then to say that like
I can't release this or whatever
nobody looked good or whatever you know
to me it's just like it's childish and
it just shows akiza he's an adult he's
gonna he has a kid which you shouldn't
bring the weddings but you have a kid
be an adult just be an adult you got
enough money you can say hey I don't
like Tim Dylan now because Trump won and
now I find him offensive or he went on
Infowars or whatever the case may be but
like I will never say like I don't like
Chris for that I don't grow I'm not
grateful to Chris bringing me on the
road when I was a young comic and I
would never say Chris isn't funny now he
was funny then but he's not funny now I
would so like I didn't do anything so
it's odd to me that he would you know
say that about me on on reddit it's very
interesting um and of course I you know
says Simon Says all my love and respect
you know I mean what are you gonna do
you know and uh listen man here's a deal
to anybody out there that has to make a
living watching comedy and and and
reading about it and watching it and
paying attention to it and then
commenting on it you guys deserve all
your money you deserve all your [ __ ]
money I mean I not a aim for me and for
me you know I'm a real estate investor
okay okay I'm a real estate investor I
am really not even a comedian I'm barely
a podcaster I have a jewelry company
that is massive and it's a direct
marketing sales company was the best
high-quality low-cost jewelry for the
American family I'm a real estate
investor I have I of a IIIi I'm a dealer
in iconic properties big ticket items
and that's where I'm an expert all right
folks
good luck out there until next week
again not shooting on Chris like Chris a
little disappointed in him
but that's okay that is okay I respect
him I wish him the best
no baby at the wedding